[Music]
in fashion first news submitted by
Brandon Choi they asked me you know
because he looks up a lot of these
articles so he should she should get up
I shout out reddit it's where I find
most my articles
ASOS baffles people with faux wireless
headphones sold as fashion accessories
so I'm just gonna show you guys because
I think the picture says a lot you said
who did brand called ASOS baffles people
with fake wireless headphones sold as
fashion accessories so you know air pods
right yeah well imagine if they well
didn't do anything
wow they really are fast yeah they're
literally just and they they just go in
your ears right there
yeah and they still look like air pods
reminds me of like this high school
thing where like people would have the
ear buds for an iPhone but they was just
plugged into nothing really yeah that
was a thing like you know iPod or
whatever people trying to be antisocial
like you didn't want to talk to people
it could be interpretive that - cuz I've
never I've never seen that at least in
my a high school I feel like everyone
that had headphones in was like
listening to something I can't see that
with my sister though cuz my sister is
one of those new age kids now who's like
I'm in some golfing or whatever am i a
toddler crater which by the way um I
shot Muse video with him back in high
school who the key was like this kids
weird whatever yeah Casey Veggies it's
all good like really like bang mm eh or
whatever first music video and in it but
I was like yeah she went to some concert
or whatever and like see she's got some
sweater cuz she was cold and like there
was one that was like regular price and
there was one that was like oh there's
golf I gotta get that - cup of coffee
but like she'd be the same person he
would right to wear one of these yeah
just for the fashion statement a lot of
people here are bringing up the fact
that it's like yeah I mean you could
also just get knockoff air because
there's so many companies in making a
knockoff air pods now you could just get
them and put why do you knew I had these
in our
well having a parabola for those real no
these are not real because Apple does
not make black air pie some stupid
reason China medic China got me these
thanks China
thank you - [ __ ] might be a little
weird given of carp you also get like a
skin for like regular white air pods -
this expensive is [ __ ] how much how much
are we talking about the air the the
faker or the real ear pods and then see
the realizing continuum yeah yeah how
much is the real ones actually cost the
$2 they like 180 and then if you wanted
to get them black you would have to get
I think you get accustom get them custom
done yeah yeah they're official guys
damn y'all are crazy
like they connect oh by the way if you
guys want these are called black pots
not sponsored by the lame totally found
this through but what's that guy unbox
therapy oh yeah he's like yeah I mean
they don't sound as good but you know
they were do air pods really sound like
that amazing like does anybody have ear
buds yeah okay for like Wireless I feel
like but they don't even like completely
like seal in your ears right you're
gonna TP team Apple soon though that's
true I'm like it I might get an iPhone
11 Pro that's right everyone's always
telling me and Julia be like oh you know
you know you know having problems cuz
you [ __ ] Android or whatever I'm like
well okay fine then I'm gonna get the
nicest iPhone that's currently I hate it
I can say definitively I [ __ ] hate it
let's be honest you know like three
years ago we call the air pods and now
wireless headphones I do have a pair of
wireless like just Bluetooth earbuds I'm
not paying $200 for every pods like
sorry oh yeah people always got to you
too because you screw up our group
messages oh yeah I get it make
everything green joke's on you any group
messages so I don't get to mess anything
up we're Albert here Antoine okay so
with those is an accessory yeah it's
just an accessory okay well I mean I
could I could kind of see it kind of
working for people who don't want to
pierce their ears and they still kind of
want to like look cool on there
but only game is weird no as far as I
can tell it's just the one design it's
like that silver kind of like fits in
your ear canal let me see it thing it's
coming like that oh that's gross looking
yeah it's spindles out thing right there
yeah and it's got a little it's got a
little hole in it that you could maybe
put something through I don't know why
but it looks like a removable showerhead
oh yeah I wondered so is that prong
removable like is that is that like a
loophole that way they could basically
make their pauses I'm making it air
maybe pay another $4.99 am i yes how
much like cause guess how much they cost
guys Oh God like a supreme type of thing
where it's like hey you wanna buy this
brick did Gina buy the break it's like a
fashion statement thing it's like it's
like they're made out of zinc by the way
what does that mean what does think
commonly used in common items I don't
know it's used a lot in like cheap
metals it's used to mix it I'm gonna go
26 it's like it says I think this is a
British company cuz it says five pounds
five or six pounds yeah I mean I like
three of them then because I'd rather
like oh those things are heavy to buy
literally anything else was inked no
it's five pounds of the [ __ ] Curb
Your Enthusiasm song yeah I mean is
there any other is are there any fashion
accessories or anything like that cuz of
the night in hindsight and we're like
that was dumb like I don't know why I
bought one of those oh I did when the OC
was out Ryan whatever his name the main
character out there always wore these
bracers right okay I was like all that
was it make like a metal bracelet or is
it uh you could get a medal by the one I
had was it the letter letter line I
didn't have like you know the little
buds on the back so I thought like a
coolest thing ever oh do be my way looks
like a gladiator
gladiator you're like a Wonder Woman
yeah so I had a watch that had that same
design but a little different and I had
another one actually with another one so
that like to I like to watch our
becoming Wonder Woman you're like
corsets are [ __ ] in red yeah that
would be terrified though if I saw some
dude down the street and of course that
with braces on with the last time you
like oh boy that guy sounds like you
need to go to more Colin's that's true
no I have been Tuco what if it's like
all of those things but it's not Wonder
Woman stuff so it's just like straight
up of course sad just straight up a
lasso it just looks like a homeless
person another day in LA yeah it's just
like sounds sounds form-fitting and
shapely Metiria I can see like in black
leather I want to question it alright
you know they go with hide now you
actually hide still makes sense to me
because they'll be going like a
Renaissance Fair see I like you make
costumes though like Devin Devin Devin
enjoys meeting costumes so he knows he
knows a fair amount about about
materials and the properties of those
materials Julia wait mr. Joker's was
Trevor's everything for you oh god I
could never do choker like I feel like I
would literally die if there was
something around my neck like ah please
cut it up even turtlenecks was very
suffocating I mean I couldn't do it
because it's like itchy right like
that's how I feel when my like my shirt
rides up to you I am singing yeah for me
like wearing dress shirts I don't like
to button up the top one cuz it feels so
constricting that's interesting because
I don't mind buttoning that top button
only button up for a time yeah yeah not
by the rare occasions but like even then
sometimes I'll just undo the top button
and let the tie be a little looser
hi bees you've never done anything that
you were like that was TV housing
your dumb purchases Brandon put the
showers over and puka shells oh my god
why your bro didn't like freshman in
high school it's like I don't want to
call it Hawaiian but it's like kind of
like Islander looking like those tiny
little shells it was like these
Hawaiians shared these Jesus I'm just
imagining to be toy with puka shells and
like a pink with a with a pink button up
with like the collar
I'll [ __ ] fireball like spudger
[ __ ] college bro Brandon I've shoes
made out of cork my airmax 90s oh wait
how do they stay together this is made
out of cork Wow another just go is the
whole soul man at a corker who's now the
whole shoe is made out of court what's
all the soul isn't is it comfortable
it's comfortable squeaks more like it is
more like an art piece I guess it's not
not a lot like it's it's like it doesn't
work like a shoe how much do those cost
though under something oh that's not too
bad I thought it's a retail guy for
retail if it was gonna be like my stuff
my resale anymore like if I could get
something cool for retail I'll get it
but back then in high school I'd buy I
every week all my all my paychecks as a
cashier at Asian supermarket was going
to Jordans I would go to her mall at
6:00 a.m. wait in mind holy [ __ ] you're
one of those and I saw them all that
makes sense yeah it sounds like your
stock portfolio speakers probably
sneakers is probably like the most
ridiculous stuff I still have a few
pairs I have never worn in my life I
feel like a majority of my friends have
shoes they have like their I'll go
through like one to two pairs a year I
just wear those like every day I feel
like I buy like three or four pairs of
shoes at a time because I'm like oh I
like the idea of these four shoes or
whatever but then I'll wear all of them
and I'll figure out which one I end up
liking and I'll wear that one the most
like I'm wearing those those air max 90
s you got me yeah those ones are the
ones that I wear most frequently yeah
would it leastly like that's the way to
actually make your shoes last longer is
if you cycle them yeah that makes sense
wait it's like they kind of have time to
like decompress between use cuz I know
like KC nice dad that's why he buys like
four or five pairs at a time because it
sounds like he'll basically run and then
like he'll swap it out so basically
it'll give it like a week so I'd
actually like decompress
extends the life there so that's also
because he's running though right that's
a different kind of pressure than just
in everyday walking that's also tasty
nice some interesting habits it's like
showing like it's like 600 cameras that
he's like I threw this off a building
and it doesn't work anymore I broke my
macbook but I got another one now yeah I
can't believe I had to wait an hour he
stalks the only person I know that
stockpiles cameras right look you know
like laptops isn't in LA now yeah he was
always absolutely worked across the
street from his office oh that must have
been a mess yeah people showing up all
the time and stuff yeah he's riding his
bike through traffic getting hit hard no
he's writing his boosted board that's
that's a thing this is a electric
electric skateboard end up looking like
me later video so stay tuned ah yeah we
can rebuild him we have the technology
wait does that still happen here because
I'd like the whole people show up
outside cuz I remember back in the day
people used to show up to this office a
lot like we'd be here working and like
literally I remember there was one time
someone just came knocking the door just
like just a dad and his kid and there's
kind of standing there yeah that's
really weird I don't know you know I
know I think JKL had enough people or
people I think they they had a new
session where there's this like yeah
parent and their kid or whatever and
they like came while they were filming
and then was like hey we just wanted to
say hi and okay we're you know kind of
filming right now I tried to be nice and
they're like well can she just like say
hi because like I'm here and they're
like no so don't do that don't don't go
to people's places of business and like
just barge in cuz it's really rude and
it's kind of scary especially we don't
know these people because actually
working yeah you get all kinds of people
that come through and sort of like
Philip DeFranco had some dude like
randomly walk into his studio while he
was building yeah
while he was filming of PDS it was like
talking to Cameron that all the sudden
his door oh this dude Cameron was like I
just wanted to meet you he's like oh
those regular dudes off carries like hey
how's it going yeah okay however you
guys find where our businesses like
don't give him ideas no because like
there's one time this dude actually
visit us at our new office and he was
walking by and means you're sitting out
I was there too yeah and like the Stig
was like whoa no way oh my god and I was
like how did he know where we are and he
was like oh and I was like oh yeah how'd
you get in cuz it's kind of like a
closed-off area way way off oh no I just
saw like a visitor's parking and a
visitor's entrance and I was like man
huh and then and then he was like I you
know I was just checking out the place
and then you guys just saw I would be
here Mike no one checks out our office
because because it's literally just
other I like fashion companies and
industrial companies and stuff that are
in there like there's no reason for you
to be there you guys like I'm I like
wanna emphasize not like we don't want
to meet you guys cuz we really do and
that's why we have meeting greets
but when it's at our own business and
it's during business hours it's not
polite as it's not and it can be kind of
scary yeah it's you don't know these
people and they're just showing up and
it's kind of like if someone like just
showed up at your house and he has like
I want to meet you only no we honestly
really appreciate all the love and the
support that you guys give us it's just
that like we there's a reason why we
have meet and greets where it's like an
area that we all feel safe sorry a snack
but like it's an area where we all feel
safe and we're setting aside the time to
like meet you guys that way like the
interaction is better to like we have
more time to like hang out and stuff
like we're not taken aback by like Oh
what the sudden if we're working we
might not be like in the zone to
actually like be able to meet people
just because like we're so focused on
trying to guess her and test them that
like if we forget to do it then we get
in trouble you know so so please
understand that mmm at same time I kind
of don't knock them because like I feel
like like it's weird cuz YouTube has
actually become yeah well we all know
it's become like the new TV and stuff
like that so like so when you think of
it you are like I could see like from an
audience point of view works
same as if your watch if you see like a
movie or a TV show being filmed where
it's like to us it's like sheds maybe an
office but to them these areas are a
character in and of itself right and so
there's that disconnect I think that
YouTube is nice because it is the most I
feel like the moment one of the most
accessible forms of like media and
entertainment so I get it I just like I
feel like those boundaries need to kind
of be like hey yeah like it's developing
thing that yeah it definitely needs to
be established because I think there's
that overlap of TV because you think of
like when TV it's like okay you have the
keys and actors like oh hey how's it
going they're working but there's that
second as opposed to the amount of soap
contained and the amount of hats people
are wearing where it's like this is
still an office place as opposed to it
being a set yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not
a good look just like these headphones
that is why use our Donald Glover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]